[Musica]
[Applauso]
1949 un pilota dell'aviazione militare
americana larry davis si reca
all'ambasciata di parigi dichiara quando
volava sul territorio della francia
germania italia notai che il paesaggio
ea tutto uguale non c'erano frontiere
erano uguali distesa di natura perciò mi
considero non più cittadino americano al
cittadino del mondo e personale sti
fisco il passaporto
la rinuncia alla cittadinanza americana
fece colpo
parigi si entusiasmo i grandi premi
nobel a in stadi citera aderirono alla
nuova idea dai cittadini del mondo la
con movimento che anche in italia e gli
sviluppi in tante città
un anno dopo a dicembre del 1950 a
ginevra si tenne l'assemblea dei popoli
una gigantesca assemblea con centinaia
di delegati fa cui deputati di 40 paesi
e del fu decise in quei cinque giorni di
creare un registro internazionale dove
raccogliere firme in vista della
costituzione di un governo
unico mondiale è una idea molto
suggestiva che in italia aveva già avuto
un precedente in un libro del famoso
scrittore antifascista borghese che ha
redatto un progetto per un governo unico
mondiale e che aveva già avuto
all'assemblea costituente un deputato
onorevole damiani che rappresentava un
gruppo di mondialisti allora io
entusiasta di questo progetto così
suggestivo per la pace universale
dedicai ogni mese due colonne
dell'incontro il periodico carron al 49
fondato intitolando questa rubrica e i
cittadini e del mondo
e così coltiva i in tutte le iniziative
pacifiste che in galera si sviluppavano
e in italia e questo movimento durò fino
agli anni 80 poi come capita spesso per
le cose umane no con l'unione europea ma
non acque per adesso il governo unico
mondiale che risolverebbe evidentemente
tutti i contrasti tra i blocchi
antagonisti continuare spiegando che io
ebbi una vita molto intensa durante la
resistenza sono prima ancora nel 42 sono
stato per tre mesi più detenuto nelle
carceri giudiziarie per disfattismo fu
l'inverno più freddo del secolo
e su quello che bloccò l'avanzata dei
carri armati tedeschi in russia e poi
successivamente e fui catturato in modo
di e un po drammatico perché il gorilla
fascista che vede da restarmi gli sparò
tre colpi di pistola due finirono nel
muro il terzo mi colpì dietro ma un
portasigarette di metallo bloccò il
colpo e si accartocciò però io mi salvai
il gorilla quando vivi di disteso al
suolo vivo di accendi un cero alla
madonna non posso io sono un libero
pensatore bump ed ho fatto i miracoli
mio padre era un ebreo non praticante
mia madre o la cattolica non praticante
a casa mia non si parlava mai di
religione e quando vennero le leggi
razziali
gli amati si preoccupa di mio fratello e
mia sorella più giovane di me ci sono
defunti e gli fece battezzare in base
alla legislazione fascista i battezzati
figli di matrimonio misto erano di razza
ariana
io che non avevo nessuna religione
gli oppositori essere libro che fu
consigliato di razza ebraica così dallo
stesso padre dallo stesso martin siano
due figli ariani e un ebreo questo
palese alla serietà della
nella legislazione fascista che ha un
assurdo che predicava una razza italiana
che non è mai esistito perché l'italia è
stata oggetto di occupazione da parte
dei francesi tedeschi spagnoli tre
secoli di armi sicilia insomma non
esiste per fortuna la razza italiana ma
un paese disponibile ad accogliere i
migranti che devono essere i benvenuti e
non ho studiati per quelli di cai ha
tante iniziative dal 49 difesi il primo
obiettore di coscienza al servizio
militare pietro pina e da allora ho
difeso centinaia di obiettori quasi
tutti i testimoni di geova che si
battevano per la libertà di coscienza e
domande in t rurale militari e poi da
quella passione che mi condusse in cui
essi film dibattiti eccetera eccetera
al 72 quando finalmente fu riconosciuto
questo diritto e fu istituiti servizi
civile volontario poi attualmente mi
occupo dei problemi così importanti
della società
non so quelli dell'ambiente cioè il
consumo dell'acqua che non devesse
privatizzato e sotto l'altro soprattutto
i miei legni che scaturiscono da quei
delinquenti che seppelliscono i rifiuti
tossici avvelenando le falde acquifere
l'ambiente climatico che ha trasformato
il paese
tutto il mondo sia attraverso uragani
sia innalzando le temperature e chissà
quali saranno gli sviluppi futuri
mi sono occupato di altri problemi sono
tutti quello dei migranti
mi sono occupato del laicismo insomma ho
cercato di carlo è la mia vita al bene
comune
confido che un giorno siamo tutti i
cittadini del mondo tesi alla pace alla
fatalità e soprattutto alla licenza del
bene supremo la libertà
[Applauso]
[Musica]